would you guys okay so we were talking  about like the millionaire wouldn't take  the only fan seriously and um most  people say like in order to become a  millionaire you have to have at least  six streams of income so would you guys  genuinely in in a relationship or even  like as a married couple would you guys  pass off an opportunity for stream of  income if your wife was inviting you to  create the only fans content with you  absolutely  yeah  putting out her body you're making it  with her it doesn't matter I wouldn't  sell that would anyone screw their wife  on camera for only fans nope sexual  stuff raise your hand I don't know yeah  anyone would do it anyone oh thank you  I would take three jobs night days  she didn't have to show your face to  make sure that right I wouldn't have to  do that  in the week six months agree it's a  creepy culture